giving each other a hard hearing enough
not ridicule in front of 500 feet of
your peers now getting promoted from
captain Admiral what happened to the
Navy the Navy ridicules and like makes
fun of a 19 year old kid and he ends up
committing suicide you're gonna make fun
of somebody because they're in a bad
spot that's not right that's not Navy
I'm from own up to your mistakes and
make them happen and make a change and
fix them that captain should have been
frickin court-martialed by the Admiral
and thrown out of the Navy somebody
should look all this up
Hicks strong Mike and Jolie Hicks during
my friends to mom and dad who lost her
son lost a wonderful saw lost lost her
kid and I just say to everybody out
there just everybody makes mistakes
everybody does stuff but that captain
immediately as soon as he did that in
front of all those people and found out
the kids started having some issues
should have gone down there with his
division officer everybody else and then
said something to kid personally with
his officers and the Chiefs and said you
know what son I made a mistake I didn't
know how can we make this right
and then in front of all 500 people two
people he said it all too should have
made a point says you know what I made a
mistake the other day and here's a young
seaman and we're gonna make sure there's
a take care of we're gonna fix this and
I was wrong and I will I will take my
punishment whatever it is I'm gonna lose
my ship I will lose that I'm gonna get I
am in trouble because I made fun of that
kid in front of everybody I did the
wrong thing then and we'd have you know
he'd be here still
mm-hmm I would imagine that that sort of
behavior happens a lot in the military
especially like the Marines and the
seals we're tough would yell each other
right look up at 2:00 a.m. this morning
to do a thousand push-ups what you do
you suck you're weak I hate that
attitude I mean I don't care our time
you wake up in the morning and how many
pushups can do you went they have
goggles the guy's a freakin monster but
yeah comes down to it not everybody has
the ability to do a thousand pull-ups
but if you can do 100 me and rock on if
that's what you can do I'm proud of you
but I'm never gonna make fun of you
because you can do it
you can do a hundred you can only do ten
it's your capability to strengthen
weakness you're still on a team you just
might not be the quarterback you might
not be the lineman hey how about a
defensive man just try get there there's
a spot for you on a team but those
people that just like they they do that
macho make it fun ridicule do you have
really killed me to make me better no
man that doesn't make me better man it
speaks volumes coming from someone like
you because you dominating in an alpha
personality that you were and the stuff
that you went through is is beyond
masculine and macho like wait hold on
you're saying alpha and macho define
alpha when I'm talking about alpha and
macho obviously there are two different
things but when I say alpha I'm
referring to a trait to where you're
someone who is a dominating force and
someone who is looked up to by many
different people who are obviously going
in the same direction and they look up
to that person and that person is a
strong example for them okay so when you
talk about domination talk about how oh
we're talking about like lions you're
talking about the animal kingdom you're
talking my strength it's a primal thing
and we talk about alpha and macho is it
sometimes it has nothing to do with like
how many pushups you can do right you
woke up at 3:00 a.m. and did a hundred
push-ups I don't care dude right when
was the last time you helped somebody
when was the last time you did something
good for somebody once the last time you
actually ate compassion and said hey
ma'am us walking past this person man
and I saw that they're sleeping in her
car and I was just like dude I'm in a
hurry but you know what not gonna win to
the car and then put the window down and
they're scared because I think they're
gonna be they're gonna get beat up or
something Bad's gonna happen and all you
do is just slip in a $20 bill I think
what I'm getting at
I like alpha compassion is there a way
to be alpha compassion is that the Dalai
Lama is that Gandhi yeah I think what
I'm trying to get it I think the point
I'm trying to explore is the fact that
you've been through the the peak of what
someone would think of alcohol or macho
that's who I mean it's who you are -
it's a life that you lived right I wanna
go I'm alpha to be alpha gandhi's right
to make them at the same equal playing
field that if you're if you're that dude
if you're David Goggins who freakin love
the guy he's awesome he's amazing and he
is an alpha like competitive and like
just he's a monster he's also like his
mentality he's just like he goes yeah
but he should be at the same level as
far as alpha measurement as I have a
friend of mine married who's just this
amazing spiritual leader but she weighs
like 90 pounds and she could probably do
ten push-ups
but shouldn't they be equals because
there's alpha domination of one whole
thing is one thing and if you want to
look at them the same but nobody will
ever look at them the same nobody will
have a you know you have a very unique
perspective and I think that you're able
to look at it that way do you think that
a lot of people with that mentality that
think that that's how you need to be or
people are raising their kids saying you
need to be a man you need to be tough
you need to play football do you think
that comes from insecurity that that may
not be there maybe I'm insecure or I'm
not confident that I am manly so I need
to really project this image
maybe I mean that's 100% possible it's
probably totally true but the thing is
when we're thinking about that you got
to be tough
well I want to say you got to be tough
when they're sitting there with their
book and they're reading the chapter to
report on just finish the chapter they
only read halfway through and they want
to go outside and play no no you got to
be mentally tough you got to be tough
just keep reading well you didn't read
it
let's read it again that's toughness
that's like an intellectual toughness
you know the extra reading assignments
are in a summer time that you just want
to play and have fun but you need to get
through these ten books during the
summer every summer read ten books every
summer if you're in school get your list
you're gonna read those because you're
mentally tough you're like macho what -
intellectual machoism mm-hmm don't just
measure it by how much you can run and
jump and do push-ups and pull-ups we
need to start measuring a mental
toughness
and the same level as we do how many
pushups you can do or they you wouldn't
you have C cage and beat the crap out of
somebody you could win a UFC cage and
beat the crap out of somebody yeah
you're really tough but look at you know
Alan Turing that guy's way tougher than
a UFC fighter I've ever known in my life
UFC you have Smee Alan Turing was the
toughest man alive who was that mentally
and everything else he's a god invented
the computers and in 1940's during World
War 1000 okay
he killed you sir he killed himself
because of ridicule just killed himself
because he got set up and he made to
fail he was set up for failure
they got he invented modern-day
computing you got a riddle story why do
you come to me he was made to take drugs
to chemically castrate him because he
thought it was a deviant he invented all
modern-day computing okay from one
person
Alan Turing wasn't an alien it was man
did you know that's what Nikola Tesla
did yeah he was also a big part of that
so he's also one of them Tesla was a
huge firm but when you start thinking
about competing in ones and zeros ones
and zeroes and the way the whole thing
happens it really came to fruition under
Alan Turing that was when he started
doing two switches and basically the
transistors the NPT SMP and and Tim's
the whole thing when it switches because
of a because of electrical change in a
circuit it switches here switches there
honor that was basically turning it was
pre transistor transistors that's
interest all computing is based on ones
and zeros right right that was a Turing
machine it was a magic machine real
quick going back that's I didn't do that
no no yeah he was way different but I
believe Tesla he intentionally castrated
himself so he could accomplish his goals
and what he was trying to do in his life
and that he thought were more important
than I never sexuality was that to
diminish their the animal instinct of
sexuality yeah
because it was a distraction yeah yeah
yeah we were talking about mental tough
yes in your documentary you were
comparing what it took for you to run
through caves screaming with an assault
rifle versus what it was like to tell
your friends and your fellow comrades
well you felt like you were a woman like
coming out like explain the difference
in the courage it took to do that versus
the courage it took to be in combat let
me put it this way
this has been me my whole life I've just
never been able to express it but in my
mind in my soul this is me so I got
created me you might not believe that
but I know because it's how I felt our
life and it came from when I was like
before I even had thought so it's not
something that was invented or as
environmental or anything else this is
the life I was given by God this is life
life is very diverse in so many ways
that people don't even know yet like we
barely understand the DNA chain and you
know chromosomes and we've barely
scratching the surface of who we are as
human beings so we're gonna define and
say no it's only one of the other yes
that's not naive there's like a thousand
levels between all of that between male
and female there's a thousand million
combinations mm-hmm so who can say it's
only black or white it's this or that
it's male or female it's not so just
there's gray just there's a lot of grey
between all that and I knew that at a
fair young age because I was I am you
were dealing with it so so here's how I
tell you to compare to Haven
scuba-diving
all the time I grew up scuba diving okay
so anyone else that a scuba dive is
gonna totally get this so imagine you're
living your entire life underwater with
a scuba bottle on and a regular in your
mouth so when you're scuba diving and
you're thinking about your breathing you
have to always think about how you're
breathing you're thinking about where
the regulator is a grader comes out I'm
in trouble gonna get back in you always
think about the level of air in your
tank you're thinking about your depth
you think about all of it at all times
your survival is critical upon
everything with the apparatus to breathe
that's transgender
so my entire life when I was born until
February 28th 2012 I was underwater on
breathing apparatus totally afraid for
my life at every second for every word I
said
every action everything I did on
February 28th of 2012 I said the heck
with it and I came above water
I dropped my scuba tank I dropped it all
off and I started living and not
worrying about anything that's how it is
to come out because now I don't need to
worry about anything because I'm above
water now I'm not worried about how I
breathe how I at what I say how would I
wear I'm not worried about anything
anymore like I was under water
that's what it feels like that's a
beautiful analogy that's how you should
think about it so for anyone everyone
that yourself you're not transgender I
don't know but you're living your life
you've always been in Buffalo so for you
to look at me and I finally come out of
the water and I go holy cow this is so
amazing you look at me and go what are
you talking about cuz you've never knew
it like you never knew what it's like to
be underwater you never had to worry
about every word every action how you
dressed what you did you never had to
worry about your survival depending on
your life and now that you're above
water now you start getting ridiculed
because now you're above water and I go
no it feels better for me and you're
gonna point Amina go we have it you look
weird you're not doing it right
you don't look right like everybody else
I say how do you know what it's like to
live underwater how do I know what it
was like to live above water my whole
life I don't so you have to think about
it totally differently and can't you
respect the fact that now I'm living and
I feel better can you say well I didn't
know what it's like to live underwater
and you're happier now I fear so yeah
right on man good job
good job for you not to worry about
every second your lives
[Laughter]